you just have so much desperation as a
comic at first just being like I need
people to come to the shows and now
they're finally coming I can take a
breath but no dude I did a rooftop one
during the pandemic because I'm like
people are gonna forget about me I'm
nervous I'm losing steam here that
sounds like traits of alcoholism yeah
maybe
we're all addicts alcoholics in here
like uh all sober nerds and I think that
this built-in discomfort this anxiety
this feeling everything's not gonna be
okay like I gotta try and do something
so I'll be okay yeah and also understand
it but just can go away so easily I've
just watched so many good Comics just
kind of take their foot off the gas and
you can lose it you can lose being funny
you can lose the audience there's so
many things you can lose so I've been so
nervous about it I did a special on
YouTube and that really helped people
come out to shows it's like over 12
million views on YouTube now I had big
Comics being like don't put out a
special for free comics I really respect
I was like I'm gonna do